كالمخدر بات اللبناني يعيش ايامه في ظل
الانهيار الاقتصادي المستمر والدولار الذي
حلق عاليا بسعر صرفه خلال الايام الماضيه
فبات عاجزا عن مقاومه ما يحصل لياتي هبوط
سعر الصرف اليوم عاديا لمواطن تاقلم على
كل شيء غير اعتياديه
يعني الي معه
سلامي الذي اعلن فيه رفع سعر الدولار على
منصه صغيره الى
38,000 ليره للدولار تقريبا
الى فتره معينه فقط
اللي كلنا متاكدين منه لانه هذا الشيء صار
بنهايه العام 21 اليوم عم يصير بنهايه
العام 22 التي توفي في بيان حكيمي مصرف
لبنان تطرقه الى عمليات تهريب الدولار الى
الخارج والتي ساهمت في الازمه تخبط
بالموضوع السياسي في تخبط بالبلد ما في
اصلاحات بنفس الوقت في ضغط على الدولار
الامريكي في مضاربه بشكل مش معقول هي كمان
سبب كبير انه عم يرفع الدولار همم ان نحنا
لاحظنا بالارقام انه الاستيراد للبنان صار
تقريبا 17 مليار دولار وهذا يمكن بياكد
الشيء اللي عم يحكي حكي مصري في لبنان انه
همم عم بيكون في ضغط على الدولار لسوريا
والارقام يلي بتقول لي 17 مليار دولار
اليوم استيراد للبنان يعني هذا شيء بياكد
كمان انه نحن اليوم عم نستورد لاقتصادين
مش لاقتصادي واحد يحاول نصفه لبنان
امتصاص الكتله النقديه الكبيره من العمله
اللبنانيه
يتم استخدامها في تاجيج عمليه المضاربه
على العمله وشراء الدولار من السوق
السوداء لكن مخاوف الخبراء ان كانت
ايجابيه هذه الخطوه ستكون محدوده المده
انتخاب رئيس للجمهوريه تشكيل حكومه
التدقيق المالي الجنائي والاصلاحات التي
يطلبها صندوق النقد الدولي كفيله ببدء
رحله الخروج من الانهيار الاقتصادي بدلا
من قرار مصر في لبنان الذي اعتبره عدد من
الخبراء حلا مؤقتا غير مضمون ناهد يوسف
العربيه بيروت